that's Blake Shelton and Gwen Stefani
performing their duet go ahead and break
my heart
on Mondays episode of The Voice he was
with the country star moments before the
lovebirds hit the stage started this
song and wrote about half of it and sent
it to her and and she wrote the other
half of it you know and it was just kind
of something for she and I I think to
help us feel better about what we were
going through and I learned a lot from
going when it comes to songwriting
already I mean because she's so brutally
honest in her writing I mean they'd go
back to you know the tragic kingdom'
album she's just telling you something
that just happened to her you know and
so I got to share it in that with the
writing of this song and it's pretty
special to me anyway wonder have you
gone back and kind of revisited her
catalogue since you started dating
that's all I do is not go back and it's
funny because I still discover songs
that I know almost by heart that I
didn't even know she's the one that sang
them Hey Baby was the last one that I
was like that's you that was y'all song
so it's exciting is still to be like oh
you're famous you're so famous and it
looks like you had so much fun at the
Angry Birds premiere did that score you
some cool points with her boy well you
know what I don't know if it's Gordon me
some cool points because you know there
was Jason Sudeikis and all the actors
were there I think I kind of faded off
into their youth the blur I know they're
so used to me hanging around it's just
Blake to them so well that's good